all of the matter in our solar system
would join the accretion disk around the
black hole as matter gets sucked into
the black hole it generates massive
amounts of radiation so even if we
somehow survived all the asteroids we'd
likely die from the radiation
while this may be a possibility with a
black hole and our sun
extreme tidal forces would likely make
our planet uninhabitable
worse yet we might get kicked out of
orbit or swallowed by the Sun or the
black hole eventually
sorry but there's not an outcome where
we win here
but and this is a big butt
maybe we find a way to protect ourselves
in some hyper-reinforced space shuttle
if